ce qui a fait beaucoup agir c'est
l'attitude qu'il y a Mbappe qui avait
fui les médias puissant exprimés pour la
première fois depuis le début du Mondial
celui-là franchement il fait un petit
peu ce qu'il veut à mon sens fou en fait
voilà c'est la faute d'aller parler
franchement excusez-moi aux médias mais
franchement total bien sûr qu'est-ce
qu'on s'en fout en fait il a marqué des
buts il a fait son match après tu dois
aller en plus faire en conférence de
presse allez répondre à des gars qui
vont te dire à la 17e minute quand vous
avez pris le ballon mais si je m'en
branle et joue sur les audiences
l'équipe de France il payera lui c'est
combien on sait pas encore vous savez
comment Gilles Verdez à peu près 30000
euros peut-être 1000 euros
moi ça m'énerve je sais pas je dois être
la seule que ça énerve mais en fait on
demande de parler aussi pour ton public
tu as un public qui te suit et peux
l'entendre s'exprimer ils veulent plus
ils voient de Killian plus ils sont
heureux donc ils ne voient sur le
terrain ensuite il le voit s'exprimer
les réseaux il y a personne
pour les téléspectateurs
c'est pour les journalistes pour prendre
derrière une phrase tu connais bien ça
en plus je crois qu'en plus dans tes
compétitions comme ça peut-être que je
me trompe mais je crois que c'est une
obligation
comme en Ligue des Champions homme du
match tu es obligé d'aller répondre mais
après effectivement du match en plus la
tanasse d'aller parler
ils ont signé
tu t'es planté tout ça on te demande d'y
aller sinon tu as 5000 dollars de de
pénalité qui va t'énerver ça gazon là tu
as gagné tu as mis des beaux buts
prendre une minute pour dire un mot
c'est pas très compliqué quand même OK
cette coupe du monde il ne pense qu'à ça
il ne vit que pour ça foutez-lui la paix
ça va gâcher moi je suis sorti Mbappé
là-dessus mais à 100 tout va bien 1000%
je vous le dis et oui non juste sur les
audiences France Pologne ça fait 2
millions de téléspectateurs de plus que
8e de fièvre de 2018 c'est là qu'on voit
que le boycot de la Coupe du Monde il
est complètement bidon en fait
exactement il y avait des sondages qui
disait que 30 % des gens regarderaient
pas ça se sent pas dans les audiences ça
marche même plus que la Coupe du Monde
2018 alors il y a une différence entre
des gars qui s'énervent voilà les bobos
qui s'énervent de leur côté et qui
disent on va boycoter tout et n'importe
quoi et le vrai monde qui comme on
continue à vivre et qui prendra des
décisions quand il faudra les prendre et
qui se dit la couillon d'aller
maintenant le Qatar et ben on soutient
notre équipe et c'est comme ça et voilà
et si elle avait été autre part on
l'aurait soutenu aussi quoi qu'il arrive
les bobos c'est un monde des champs il y
va toujours pour dire rien deux fois
n'était pas mal le premier attention
[Musique]
n'était pas mal aussi mais calme-toi
[Rires]
la Coupe du Monde cartonne voilà il y a
deux mondes parallèles de toute façon en
France il y a un monde composé 10 % de
personnes de bobo qui font beaucoup de
bruit mais que plus personne n'écoute de
moins en moins et 90 % des gens qui font
leur vie et qui sont bien heureux de pas
avoir de compte à donner à rendre au
bobo allez c'est parti
je voulais m'exprimer avant la première
question parce que je sais qu'il y avait
pas mal de questions sur Pourquoi je
parlais pas déjà tous les journalistes
ils sont là c'était rien de personnel
j'avais rien contre les journalistes
rien contre les gens c'est juste que je
sais que j'avais besoin de j'ai toujours
ce besoin de me concentrer sur ma
compétition et je sais que quand je veux
me concentrer sur quelque chose j'ai
besoin de le faire à 100 % et de pas
perdre d'énergie dans d'autres choses et
c'est pour ça que je souhaitais pas me
présenter et j'ai appris un peu que la
Fédération elle allait avoir une amende
donc je m'engage à la payer
personnellement il faut pas que la
fédération est paye une décision qui est
personnelle